i feel like i've been incredibly blessed
in my career so far did emma watson just
retire from
acting people seem pretty convinced
that's the question
everyone is asking after the 30 year old
actresses agent
told the daily mail that her career is
quote dormant
and she is not taking on new commitments
an unnamed source also told the
publication that emma has gone
underground and has been laying low with
her reported partner
leo robinton e.t has reached out to
emma's rep
for comment on her rumored retirement
all that speculation
had emma trending on twitter with fans
sharing their support
like this one who tweeted quote emma
watson has given us some of the most
iconic roles
i'm wishing her all the best for the
future she deserves this
it made me so happy but other fans are
reeling from the alleged news
tweeting things like emma watson is
retiring what don't talk to me please
and me when i read that emma watson had
retired
leave of course emma first burst onto
the scene as a child actor
playing hermione in the 2001 flick harry
potter and the sorcerer's stone
and continued playing the character in
sequels released through
2011. the british star went on to appear
in the 2012 film adaptation of the perks
of being a wallflower
the bling ring and disney's 2017 live
action remake of beauty and the beast
so what can i bring you from the market
a rose like the one in the painting her
most recent role
playing meg march in the star-studded
2009 adaptation of little women
why are they calling you daisy it's
their pet name for me
off screen emma is a un women goodwill
ambassador and
launched the he for she campaign in 2014
in response to gender inequalities yeah
i'm really excited
and back in 2009 the actress
did tell e.t this when asked about the
rumors that she might quit acting after
attending college at brown university
i just said that i wanted to be really
picky about the parts that i chose to
play
like i didn't want to just jump into
anything i wanted to be quite specific
about what i decided to do
and also you know i've been working
solidly since i was like nine years old
and
i want to have a bit of a break and i
want to go and study properly rather
than try and
do everything and not do anything
properly if that makes sense so
i'm gonna see how it goes but going to
university doesn't mean that i'm giving
up acting